open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five Sylvia's with us
in Tucson hi Sylvia how are you I'm
doing great
Dave first-time caller I've been
listening to you for a long time I'm
honored to have this opportunity to talk
to you under unfortunate circumstances
but I don't know help I need I have a
daughter that financed a car at nineteen
percent
well that was foolish how old is she
thirty-five good lord
she did that yes I think about 35 you
know that was stupid
yes and I do agree I'll tell you what
but so she did this and later on yeah I
was able to ask her after she did the
deal I was able to ask her what interest
rate and turned out to be 19 percent
well not naturally I flipped I'm the
kind of person I was taught but my
mother you you earn you earn your money
and then you can spend your money that
you spend it
why is a she was all about this was all
correct
so I am debt-free have always been I
don't believe in credit cards I can pull
all kinds of overtime and and you know
buy my vehicles that way I say next
years for a vehicle no you only did
ahead right now is my show your question
or my question is how can i how can i
protein who can I do do I approach do I
approach the lender or the dealership in
regards to either adjusting the interest
rate I I what I want to do is um I want
you knowing this she's 35 yes she has
barely an income she she she's a single
parent she needs the vehicle no she no
yeah I'm sorry no she doesn't she needs
to sell the vehicle vehicles insanity
whoa
19% 19% what was this his car worth well
it's a it's what's it worth value it's
at 17,000 yeah she's broke and she's
driving a $17,000 car yeah at 19% I told
you she had his car this car represents
stupid and she needs to sell it she
needs to sell it in your rid of it and
get rid of this problem and get her a
$2,000 beater exactly and if I purchase
I'm her dad and she wants to go that
direction and I want to help her by
buying her a $2,000 car I might do that
but mommy if she's not you know her
brains not working and so you can't go
in and fix this she's a 35 year old
suppose an adult she's got to decide
what's smart here and she's got to
realize the that the direction she is
taken is astronomically stupid yeah and
so she needs to get rid of the car and
then you if you want to write a check
give her a couple thousand dollar car
for cash no no payments and no she
doesn't owe you the money back it's a
gift and she starts living her life
smart like you and I believe from this
point forward well I'd be all for that
but I'm not gonna participate in this
insanity that she's involved in if I'm
you and you shouldn't either this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey you guys Rachael
Cruz here hope you're enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my very own YouTube channel yes that's
right kind of better
save room to channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
check out how to do a monthly budget
it's one of the best videos out there
you